ESPECIALLY ON THIS JULY 4
HOLIDAY WEEKEND, PRO-
AMERICA.
THAT'S WHERE WE START
TONIGHT.
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN BEING
PRO- AMERICAN.
[INAUDIBLE]
PRESIDENT REAGAN PUT IT
BEAUTIFULLY WHEN HE TALKED OF
A SHINING CITY ON THE HILL.
I ALSO LOVED BILL CLINTON'S
GREAT LINE, THERE'S NOTHING
WRONG WITH AMERICA THAT CAN'T
BE FIXED BY WHAT'S RIGHT WITH
AMERICA.
THIS WEEK WE STILL HAVE A
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT WHO LIKE
RONALD REAGAN IS PROUD OF
AMERICA AND HAPPY TO SAY IT,
TO CELEBRATE IT BUT TODAY'S
DEMOCRATS, NO THEY'RE
EMBARRASSED BY AMERICA.
FAR FROM CELEBRATING, THEY
WANT TO TEAR DOWN AND TURN IT
INTO SOMETHING ELSE.
THAT'S THE BACKGROUND TO THE
SALUTE TO AMERICA ON
INDEPENDENCE DAY.
THE DEMOCRATS COULDN'T WAIT TO
ATTACK IT.
>> I DON'T THINK HE GETS IT.
>> HE DOESN'T GET IT.
OKAY LOOK, HERE'S SOME OF WHAT
THE PRESIDENT ACTUALLY SAID.
TOGETHER WE ARE PART OF ONE OF
THE GREATEST STORIES EVER
TOLD, THE STORY OF AMERICA.
IT IS THE SPIRIT DURING AND
DEFIANCE, EXCELLENCE AND
ADVENTURE, COURAGE AND
CONFIDENCE, LOYALTY AND LOVE
THAT BUILT THIS COUNTRY INTO
THE MOST EXCEPTIONAL NATION IN
THE HISTORY OF THE WORLD AND
OUR NATION IS STRONGER TODAY
THAN IT EVER WAS BEFORE.
>> I THINK YOU WILL FIND JOE
CHINA THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
GETS WHAT MAKES AMERICA GREAT
BETTER THAN A SWAMP CREATURE
WHO TOOK BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN BRIBES IN THE FORM OF
PAYMENT TO HIS FAMILY
BUSINESSES FROM AMERICA'S
NUMBER ONE ENEMY.
YOU ARE THE LAST PERSON TO
LECTURE ANYONE ON PATRIOTISM.
# JOE CHINA.
BUT IT WASN'T JUST HIM.
IT WAS ALL OF THEM.
HOW DARE YOU CELEBRATE AMERICA
TRIED THE LEFT, IT'S NOT WHO
WE ARE.
>> IT'S JUST NOT WHO WE ARE AS
AMERICANS BUT WE DON'T PUMP
OUR CHEST WITH TANKS IN THE
STREET, FLY JETS OVER TO PROVE
OUR STRENGTH.
>> I THINK REDUCING OUR NATION
TO TANKS AND SHOWS OF MUSCLE
JUST MAKES US LOOK LIKE THE
KIND OF LOUDMOUTH GUY AT THE
BAR.
>> ADVOCATES A WASTE OF
MONEY.
HE'S HAVING A PARADE OUT THERE
FOR HIMSELF, PUTTING TANKS OUT
THERE FOR HIMSELF AND IF HE
WAS SERVING OUR NATION HE'D BE
INVESTING IN HIGHER PAY,
BETTER HOUSING A BETTER
HEALTHCARE.
>> THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS DONE
UNLIKE PRESIDENT OBAMA.
THE BIG POINT IS CAPTURED IN
THAT SMUG PLATITUDE PLOTTED
OUT BY THE RIDICULOUS ERIC'S
WALL WELL.
IT'S NOT WHO WE ARE.
FOR ONCE, THAT PHRASE TOLD US
SOMETHING USEFUL ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATS, JUST NOT THE WAY
THEY INTENDED.
THE PROUD AMERICANS WHO STOOD
IN THE POURING RAIN AND FROM
THE LINCOLN MEMORIAL TO
CELEBRATE THEIR COUNTRY,
THAT'S NOT WHO THE DEMOCRATS
ARE.
THE MILLIONS MORE WHO WATCHED
AT HOME AND THOUGHT FINALLY WE
HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO LOVES
AMERICA AS MUCH AS WE DO IN
ISN'T EMBARRASSED TO SAY SO,
NO, THAT IS NOT WHO THE
DEMOCRATS ARE.
THE DEMOCRATS WON'T CELEBRATE
AMERICA BECAUSE THEIR NEW
IDEOLOGY DEMANDS THAT THEY
DENIGRATE AMERICA, NOT LEAST
WITH THEIR RECKLESS DIVISIVE
LIES ABOUT CONCENTRATION CAMPS
AT THE BORDER, COLLUSION WITH
RUSSIA.
TODAY'S DEMOCRATS ARE ENGAGED
IN A CONCERTED EFFORT TO SMEAR
THIS COUNTRY AT HOME AND IN
THE EYES OF THE WORLD.
WHEN THEY TELL YOU THEY DON'T
WANT TO CELEBRATE AMERICA
BECAUSE IT'S NOT WHO WE ARE,
BELIEVE THEM.
PRESIDENT TRUMP BY CONTRAST
LAID OUT EXACTLY WHY WE SHOULD
CELEBRATE.
THE AMERICAN SPIRIT, HE TALKED
ABOUT ON INDEPENDENCE DAY HAD
DRIVEN SOME THE MOST PROFOUND
ACHIEVEMENTS IN HISTORY FOR
MEDICAL BREAKTHROUGHS TO
TECHNOLOGICAL MARVELS.
IT HAS CONTINUALLY CONFOUNDED
WHAT THE WORLD THANKS IS
POSSIBLE, BUT WHY, HOW, IT'S
NOT JUST CHANCE OR LUCK, THERE
ARE OTHER COUNTRIES JUST AS
TALENTED AND INGENIOUS.
HERE'S MIGHT SUSPECT AS A
RECENT ARRIVAL.
IT'S AMERICA'S GREATEST
ACHIEVEMENT THAT HAS MADE ALL
THE OTHERS POSSIBLE, AND THAT
IS THE GENIUS FRAMEWORK
CONSTRUCTED BY THE FOUNDERS
AND EXPRESSED IN THE FOUNDING
DOCUMENTS ALL IN-SERVICE WITH
THAT SIMPLE IDEA, IS LIBERTY
UNDER THE LAW.
IF THE GUARANTEE OF INDIVIDUAL
LIBERTY THAT GAVE THE PIONEERS
THE CONFIDENCE TO SET OUT INTO
THE UNKNOWN AND THE BELIEF
THEY COULD BUILD SOMETHING
BETTER.
THEY COULD GOVERN THEMSELVES.
POWER TO THE PEOPLE.
DECENTRALIZED AND LIMITED
GOVERNMENT.
THE RULE OF LAW.
THESE ARE THE FOUNDATION OF
THE AMERICAN SPIRIT THEY HAVE
PAVED THE WAY BUT ALSO OUR
ECONOMIC SYSTEM WHICH
INVESTMENT INNOVATION AND
SUCCESS IS REWARDED, NOT
PUNISHED.
LOOK AT THE DIFFERENCE IT
MAKES.
ANOTHER INCREDIBLE JOBS REPORT
LAST WEEK.
INCOMES RISING FASTEST, RECORD
LOW UNEMPLOYMENT AND A FAIR
ECONOMY.
FOR EXAMPLE THE GAP BETWEEN
WHITE AND AFRICAN-AMERICAN
UNEMPLOYMENT HAVE SHRUNK BY
NEARLY A HALF SINCE 2016.
THE OBAMA YEARS GAVE US LOW
GROWTH AND HIGHER INEQUALITY.
WITH OBAMA WE HAD THE EXACT
OPPOSITE LOWER IN A
INEQUALITY.
THEY BEEN CAPTURED BY AN
EXTREMIST IDEOLOGY THAT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY ANTI-AMERICAN.
YOU SOUGHT AT THE DEBATE.
IT CONNECTS EVERYTHING.
AND YES THEIR HYSTERICAL
REACTION TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
SALUTE TO AMERICA.
THEY'RE NOT CELEBRATING
AMERICA BUT DENIGRATING
AMERICA.
NOT POWER TO THE PEOPLE BUT
POWER FOR THEMSELVES ON THE
BUREAUCRATIC ELITE.
NOT DECENTRALIZED GOVERNMENT
BUT EVERYTHING CONTROLLED FROM
WASHINGTON D.C.
THE DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT
LIMITED GOVERNMENT.
THEY WANT ENDLESS, RELENTLESS
INTERVENTION BY AN
ALL-KNOWING, ALL SEEING
ALL-POWERFUL STATE.
HERE'S PERHAPS THE BIGGEST
CHANGE FROM THE DEMOCRATS OF
THE PAST.
TODAY'S DEMOCRATS DON'T EVEN
WANT THE MOST VITAL ELEMENTS
OF THE AMERICAN INHERITANCE,
THE RULE OF LAW.
AT THAT FIRST PRESIDENTIAL
DEBATE, ALMOST ALL OF THE 2020
CANDIDATES BACK TO THE
DECRIMINALIZATION OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
ON WEDNESDAY, CORY BOOKER
ASKED ESCORTED MIGRANTS TOWARD
THE BORDER HIMSELF, EVEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S FORMER
HOMELAND SECURITY SECRETARY
NOW SAYS THE DEMOCRATS ARE
EFFECTIVELY FOR OPEN BORDERS.
THE DEMOCRATS POINT TO THE
STATUE OF LIBERTY AND SAY
IMMIGRATION CONTROL IS
UN-AMERICAN.
THEY FORGET ONE VITAL THING,
IT'S NOT JUST LIBERTY, IT'S
LIBERTY UNDER THE LAW AND IT
IS THERE LATENT ASSAULT ON THE
RULE OF LAW THAT IS TRULY
UN-AMERICAN.
LET ME END ON A PERSONAL NOTE
ABOUT AMERICA.
I'M AN IMMIGRANT JUST AS MY
PARENTS WERE IN ENGLAND AFTER
THEY FLED COMMUNISM IN
HUNGARY.
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN PRO-
IMMIGRATION.
HOW CAN I BE ANYTHING ELSE BUT
IT'S ESPECIALLY THOSE OF US
WHO BELIEVED IN THE VIRTUES
AND BENEFITS OF IMMIGRATION
WHO SHOULD WANT TO SEE IT
PROPERLY CONTROLLED.
PUBLIC CONSENT DEPENDS ON
GOVERNMENT CONTROL OF
IMMIGRATION.
THAT'S WHY IMMIGRATION HAS TO
BE DONE THE RIGHT WAY
ACCORDING TO THE RULES.
THAT CERTAINLY HOW I'VE DONE
IT SINCE I MOVED HERE WITH MY
FAMILY AND I THOUGHT THIS JULY
THE FOURTH WEEKEND WAS A GOOD
MOMENT LET YOU KNOW THAT I'M
NOW BEGUN THE PROCESS OF
APPLYING FOR U.S.
CITIZENSHIP.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MUCH I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
THIS COUNTRY HAS GIVEN ME AND
THE WELCOME YOU ALL SHOWN ME